お久しぶりですはじめ車窓ですいやーうち
イタリア旅行から帰ってきましたん
なんて言うと思ったかバナーやっぱりピットは前々からねまあ場は聞いてたよ
イタリアとてもいいところでしたつまりちょっと宮中花旅行行ったわけじゃないから
そんなに動画は撮れなかったんですけどまぁ神様へがとりましたよねほんとにいいとか
でした
パスタもないしピッチャーもないし厚みが切り出し
どうも優しいただ
まあぼったくりとなるんだよなやられちまった釣りとか詐欺とかぼったくりと噛まれ
ないから上入れてるわけなんですよ
日本とは違って長い子がそういう人が多いんだよすぎ何か切断とすぐピチットくれ
みたいなお金くれみたいな
まあそれぞれがたくさんいてその子だわかったんだよだやおりゃそう簡単にいかない
いや分かってだよわかってねさと調べたからてながら
もある程度アスリートかも釣りとかぼったくりと全部もシカトしてする足なんだけども
最終日創氏はスペイン広場というねイタリアにスペイン広場というすごい有名なところ
があるんだけど
ラーメン不老庵の休日の海岸みたいなところにまぁそこで俺がね高はやっぱ最初に立っ
たかちょっと浮かれていたわけよまあそれでもスペイン耳カバーで出張つけなきゃいけ
ないことっていうのはもう
本当に33通りミサンガを着けられるとお金がとられますということはもうまえない
から切ってまあ大丈夫市長と持っていこう
フーってこう言ってたわけっすよそしたらとある潮位風をと一人学校な話しかけてきて
話しかけてくれたりさんもみさんなるってわかんないですミサンガを持ってたら部屋が
総毛だけどね御山のをてなかったのに後期てもパワーを見た
はいはい磨いてなんかウェアいう japan
これやみたいなエアージャパンジャパンって言ったら大
長友なんかと思ってこうなんとイエス流そもいやゲーみたいな子や家なんかとも言え
いいんじゃない風になっちゃってるとこなんか楽しいわけじゃ日本人士ツリー
トリアージいるんだと思っていこうちょっと店主
合っちゃって煌8位でイタリア最高
ライブみんな可愛いやいねえみたいな話をしてるといきなりですよ
チェックに使われて小指出されてこう言うねもう理由はダメ速度で
ミサンガつけられてミサンガつけられて瞬間ですではもう一人の男がやってきました
俺はその男に連れてかれミサンガをきつく縛ら姉御さんが来ている
縛られてま覚悟します手を僕もまあもうお金をあげるぐらいの気持ちでもいいよ
とってこういっただけなんですけども最初でちょっとなっていったんだよ1人目の奴が
ちょっと入るなどばやろがーとか
ただ行ったんでただ指さんがつけただけで兵みたいなニャイありがと嫌いってますねも
行ったらもう一人のところ15ユーロ
xevo yu
どっちーたら第二ねぇまぁ1600円聖なる100円ぐらいだと思ってあぁナミさんが
1個1600円1702たいあい4 way ok に切って財布を開けた瞬間そこが
ねここが俺のミスだった財布の中に結構
お札を入れてて南前川克服しちゃったけどさようなら結構入れちゃってて
最後目地た瞬間二人目のに勝也どっか
別に代わってのっ
脳のところへいらして no 15ローズ5
お札お札みたいなお外をサッとやって来てるで俺もさあそんな甘いわけで俺もねそんな
に甘くない理由
あった海上んだよを得た歯医者
yeah みたいな感じで言うとはなんかモコもうこれが入ったり
これがいたりを言って俺も負けずにどう返し
ぞ御山の大将ってろぐわーっ
の無駄に消えてきてちょっとルーフじゃないなと思ってこう
20色なんですよ20ユーロ2,600円
以前の経験が入って広芸
イェーイっ私太郎
no キュッピーってくるわけですよフィフティーズたらもう50ユーロのことすよ
まあ日本円でね6前500円玉でそのくせんまエコ技そうですよ
たらな市場に取られたらなんかそいつは5
1dl 2dl 3dl 4敗と言ってくるんですよそれどういうことだツイート
50ユーロ5枚出せってことです250ユーロ
完全に終わった手ならなかったらそれは
おりゃねーなぜかなかったんだずっと負けたくなかったから俺は粘ったよいやそれは
おかしい三番3500円ですよ
33500よこんな変なてなんかバカみたいな3三田に3番さん強いよ今日は助かって
話じゃん軍でもか運転や豚って小山会それおかしいだろ
た
長いんだよってこう言った最後を開いてたから
そしても別に立って財布から貼ってごず05枚も撮られてバイバイバイバイバイみたい
な
って感じで10久住ロ
とられましたーーー
約3万4000です
たぶん1250打ってるの
相馬4000でしょう
ああああああ
って感じで実は250ユーロ3万4000分取られました
デコいろいろネットで調べたらやっぱりスペイン広場は日本人すごい
ミサンガに詐欺とられますそれをミサンガ売りとかじゃなくてこう話し合いから入る日
さんよりクマ狩りにくいタイプです海外に行く人マジで物を売ってないような人にも気
を付けて下さい
完全に俺はない読めなかった
設置調べたけど言えなかった結構いたんですよネットで注意袋とは twitter と
かも結構
ミサンガをこうつけられてを張ってくれたって言ってたんですけども
まあ
みんなたいしたことないなみんなね所詮取られても10ユーロ永遠にじいろとかそんな
に1000円2000円とかでねそんなちまちま貯留もんじゃないや俺は
250ユーロ持ってくれましたから日本一ですミサンガで下げられたランキングだ俺が
ね今んどく日本一だと思っていますネットを見る限りで周りたり徒を楽しかったで
るっていいんですよ飯もおいしいし人もねあんな人ばっかりじゃねえ飯とか
期待したただ本当一部のせいだよこんな一番役の聖戦嫌な気分になったね
いたんやなめんなやベゼ帰ってこれだってを反らせると外国行く時は本当に気を付けて
下さい俺もう基本の人が住んでませんからなぜを考えていいわけわかんない美さんで
3万4千取られるこの家はそのまでしてツイッターの田面たけしはもう
あのイタリア者等な店だ buco